[Music]
stubborn fat that is something we all
have
issues with well we now have a
non-invasive solution
which is perfect for the pool season
let's welcome tania who is a medical
assistant at the jazzy wellness
tania tell everyone what body contouring
is and how does it work
body contouring is technology that we
have that helps permanently destroy the
fat cells
and it also includes skin tightening so
the fat cells first session you can
usually
lose two to three inches two to three
inches on your first session okay let's
break it down what areas
do you treat we can target any areas
where
um anybody wants fat removed so like the
arms the stomach
the back the legs anywhere so you said
it it's amazing
you can start seeing results of two to
three inches on your first treatment is
that when you
most people start seeing results is
after coming in for the first time
yep after the first time they'll
definitely lose a few inches and then
when we do packages of four sessions as
well and then you'll continue losing
over each session
and how many sessions are typically
needed we're looking at someone with
their arms there how many sessions are
normally needed for those kind of
results
typically four sessions four sessions
then how long how long does each session
last
um anywhere from like 50 minutes to an
hour each session
and these these before and after
pictures are just incredible you can see
the results right there on your screen
how long do these results typically last
so the fat cells are permanently
destroyed so they're gone they don't
come back
um the important thing is to keep
hydrated to help flush everything easier
out of your system
this is just incredible because the key
thing it's non-invasive
so everything we're doing this this is
safe yes it's all safe non-invasive so
it's a great alternative to surgery
um you can return to your regular
activities the same day and if someone
issues they can come see you and do a
consultation first and you kind of walk
them through everything
yes we have free consultations right now
it is amazing just looking at those
before and after photos it's incredible
the things that you can do tanya thank
you so much for joining us if you have a
special i'll run it down here
the jazzy wellness is located at 900
south valley view boulevard
suite 100 you can find them online at
thejazzywellness.com and take advantage
of this special deal guaranteed lose two
inches the same day
first 10 callers 40 off a series of body
contouring
call today 702 800 7406
in las vegas now